police say they have their man in the
murder of four University of Idaho
students we're taking a look at some of
the biggest pieces of evidence laid out
in the probable cause affidavit and
seeing where the defense might be able
to poke some holes lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber the man accused of
stabbing four young college students to
death is sitting behind bars in an Idaho
jail this as his public defender and
prosecutors from latak County prepare
for what's sure to be a very long legal
process since coburger's arrest in
Pennsylvania a week ago in the release
of the probable cause document on his
return to Idaho we have learned more
about the investigation into the
quadruple murder law enforcement sources
told CNN that the Hyundai Elantra that
coburger was driving was cleaned from
top to bottom by the suspect during
surveillance of his parents in
Pennsylvania home and co-burger's
movements sources told the media outlet
that the 28 year old doctoral student
was seen wearing surgical gloves
investigators believe coburger killed
Kaylee gonsalves Madison Mogan zaner
kernodle and Ethan Chapin inside of a
rented home not far from the University
of Idaho campus at the time of the
murders coburger was studying at
Washington State University which is
just a few miles away from the crime
scene when the semester was over he and
his father took a row road trip across
the United States in that very Hyundai
Elantra back to Pennsylvania I'm joined
by my co-hosts and legal analyst public
defender Brian buckmeyer former trial
Attorney Terry Austin all three of us
have had a chance to look over this
affidavit and while there is a lot of
evidence against co-burger it's not as
airtight as people might think Brian
you're a defense attorney where do you
see the problems all right I'll start
with the first one the pinging of the
phone associated with coburger is strong
evidence but it isn't without holes of
the defense can argue using cell towers
to track a suspect is a common practice
amongst police officers can be very
helpful but when you start digging a
little deeper doubt May grow whether
it's reasonable is up for the jury to
decide cell phone towers can have a
radius of up to 25 miles many especially
in urban areas can pinpoint a person's
phone to a closer than a mile because
there are so many Towers in a given Area
coburger's phone pings off the towers
that's in the area of the murders that
could be only maybe five to ten miles
radius or maybe less and when the school
is seven to eight miles away that
doesn't tell us much in terms of the
path of the vehicle that's more art than
science as the officer himself says he
knows the path and he deduced which way
it would go but what if there are other
roads we know that people from WSU also
go to Moscow to party so going there 12
times could have an innocent explanation
you know what Brian I actually think the
cell phone data coupled with the video
footage of the wider launcher is plenty
to convince a jury that kohlberg is the
killer we know that Cole Burger's phone
was at his residence at 242 on December
13th and then it traveled south five
minutes later the phone stopped sending
signals meaning that it was either
turned off or placed on airplane mode
the phone is then turned back on at 4 48
a.m in addition to the cell phone
evidence the authorities have
corroborating video of co-burger's white
Elantra at the scene of the crime
beginning at 3 39 a.m on the 13th the
car was ultimately seen leaving the
student Residence at about 4 20 at a
high speed of rate all of this might be
circumstantial evidence but it is enough
evidence for the jury to conclude that
coburger was at the scene of the crime
when the murders took place and the
evidence also supports the argument that
coburger intentionally turned turned his
phone off and as far as I'm concerned
he's trying to avoid detection and it's
a clear consciousness of his guilt all
right Tara I see that but that's not the
only potential problem I see in this
case the fact that we have an eyewitness
Dylan of the suspect is huge in the
description could definitely be
co-burger I think it's fair that to say
that everyone immediately went to his
eyebrows when we heard the report so
let's go there I'm on the fence does
coburger have thin eyebrows no I don't
think anyone's going to say that but
does he have bushy eyebrows bushy to the
point that they would be an identifying
feature when a person is wearing a mask
I think they're that's where reasonable
Minds can disagree and that may cause
doubt the prosecution of a course will
parade a picture of him with the
bushiest eyebrows and the defense will
get a picture where his eyebrows look
thin he's known Eugene Levy though uh
Lev sorry now Dylan will be
cross-examined on her sobriety that
night how much she slept the lighting
which could raise more than just
questions but it's not just his
appearance but how she came about it she
was the that close to the Killer and she
didn't he didn't attack her she was
frozen so scared but never checked on
her friends or called the police for
another eight hours that may raise a few
eyebrows you know what Brian I do admit
that the identification is not full
proof but it was clear and it was
concise based on DM's statement we know
that the homicide occurred between 4 AM
and 4 25 a.m now remember DM heard the
dog barking she heard Kaylee say that
someone is here she heard crying sounds
and she heard a male's voice say it's
okay I'm going to help you plus she saw
a person matching coburger's General
description passed right by her and like
you said she basically stood in Frozen
shock that would give her plenty of time
to check him out and know his appearance
so she described his appearance his
approximate height his weight his facial
hair and of course that description
could Match multiple people but only one
person matching that description drove a
white Elantra that was there at the time
of the murders and based on all that I
have very little doubt that he is the
suspect well I don't know what to
believe but then that ping-pong match
between you both but I think we
definitely got a good sense of whatever
what everything was in that affidavit